all right thanks very much for the
invitation to speak to you yeah so I'm
gonna be talking about deep generative
models so when we talk about deep
generative models what we're really
talking about here from my point of view
is to essentially train neural nets from
training examples in order to represent
the distribution from which these came
so we can think about this as either
explicitly doing density estimation
where we have some samples here and we
try to model those samples with some
density estimation or we can think of it
more like this which is what actually
I'll be doing a lot more of this kind of
thing which is essentially we're worried
about sample generation here so we have
some training examples like this where
we're sort of just natural images from
the world and Rast asking a model to
train to learn to output images like
this now these are actually not true
samples these are actually just other
images from the same training so I
believe this is from imagenet a few
years ago or even a few months ago this
would have seemed obvious that this you
couldn't generate samples like this but
in fact nowadays this is actually not so
obvious that we couldn't generate these
so it's been a very exciting time in
this area and the amount of work we've
done in the amount of progress we've
made in the last few years has been
pretty remarkable and so I think part of
what I want to do here is tell you a
little bit about that progress give you
some sense of where we were in say 2014
when this started really to accelerate
and and where we are now so yeah so so
why generative models why do we care
about generative modeling well there's a
there's a bunch of reasons some of us
are just really interested in making
pretty pictures and I confess that for
the most part that's what I'll be
showing you today is just as an
evaluation metric we'll just be looking
at pictures just natural images and how
well we're doing in natural images but
there's actually real tasks that we care
about when we talk about generative
modeling one of them is just let's say
you want to do some conditional
generation like for example machine
translation right so we're conditioning
on some source sentence and we want to
output some target sentence well the
structure within that target sentence
that
target language let's say that the the
rules the grammatical rules you can
model that structure using a generative
model so this is an instance of where we
would do conditional generative modeling
another example where this is something
that we're actually looking a little bit
towards is is can we use generative
models as outlier detection and actually
recently these types of models have been
integrated into RL algorithms to help
them do exploration more effectively
this was dot work done at deep mind I
believe so here we're looking at you
know a case where you know if you think
about kind about this is a toyish
version of the autonomous vehicle task
and you want to be able to distinguish
cars and and wheelchairs and then you're
gonna have something like this and you
don't want your classifier to just
blindly say oh I think it's either a car
or a wheelchair you want your classifier
to understand that this is an outlier
right and and you can use generative
modeling to be able to do that by
noticing that there aren't very many
things like this example from the
training set so you can proceed with
caution and this is kind of a big deal
right because we don't want our
classifiers are our neural net
classifiers are very very capable of
doing excellent performance
classification but but any classifiers
just trained to output one of the
classes that it's been given and so in
cases where we actually are faced with
something really new and that's not seen
before or perhaps in lumination
conditions that it's never been trained
to to cope with we want models that are
conservative in those cases so we hope
to be able to use generative models for
that another case where we're looking at
generative models being useful is in
going from simulation to real examples
of in robotics so so in robotics
training these robots with neural nets
is actually quite laborious if you're
really trying to do this on the real
robot it would take many many trials and
it's it's not really practical in
simulation this works much much better
but the problem is is that if you train
a policy in simulation and transfer it
to the real robot well that's not going
to work that hasn't worked very well
because the environment is just too
different but what if we could use a
generative model to make our simulation
so realistic that that transfer is
viable so this is one another area that
a number of groups are look
this kind of expression generator
modeling in this direction so there's
lots of really practical ways to use
generate models beyond just looking at
pretty pictures right so so I break down
the kinds of generative models there are
in the world in terms from two rough
categories here and maybe we can take
issue with this oh by the way if you
guys have questions go ahead and ahead
and ask me while you have them I think I
like interaction if possible or you can
just say them to the end either way is
fine and sorry for my voice I've got a
cold so yeah we have auto regressive
models and we have latent variable
models so auto regressive models are
models where you basically define an
ordering over your input right so for
things like speech recognition or
Strether's speech synthesis in the
gender and modeling case this is natural
right it's just there's a natural
ordering to that data it's just the
temporal sequence for things like images
it's a little less obvious how you would
define an ordering over pixels but there
are nonetheless models such as pixel R
and N and pixel CN n that do just this
in fact pixel CN n is a is a really
interesting model from this point of
view they basically define a
convolutional neural net with a mask so
if you remember our previous lecture we
did we saw these convolutional neural
nets but what they do is they stick a
mask on it so that you've got sort of a
causal direction so you're only looking
at previous pixels in the ordering that
you've defined the the the the well the
ordering that defined by the auto
regressive model so so you kind of
maintain this this ordering as you go
through the continent and what that
allows you to do is come up with a
generative model that's supported by
this confident that you know it's just a
full generative model and it's a it's a
pretty interesting model its own right
but because of I have rather limited
time I'm actually not going to go into
that model in particular another thing I
just want to point out here is that
wavenet is probably the state of the art
model for speech synthesis right now and
it forms the basis of very interesting
speech synthesis systems it's another
area where gender models have made a
remarkable contributions in the last few
years even the last few months so now
we're seeing models that you would be
fairly hard-pressed to just
English between natural speech and and
these kinds of models for the most part
so what I'm going to concentrate on is
latent variable models so latent
variable models are models that
essentially posit that you have some
latent variables that are hope that you
hope will represent some latent factors
of variation in the data right so these
are these are things that as you wiggle
them they're gonna move the data in in
what you hope will be natural ways right
so you can imagine a latent variable for
images corresponding to illumination
conditions right or if their face is a
common it's a common thing we find is
latent variable corresponding to a smart
right so we if we move this latent
variable the image that we see that we
generate you know a smile appears and
dissapears these are the kind of latent
variables that we want and and we want
to discover these so this is really a
challenging task in general we want to
take natural data just unlabeled data
and discover these latent factors that
give rise to the variation we see
there's two kinds of models in this
family that I'm going to be talking
about adversarial auto-encoders and
generative adversarial nuts or Ganz here
I work personally with both of these
kinds of models they serve different
purposes for me and yeah what's let's
dive in so first I'll talk about the
variation all encoders this actually was
a model was developed simultaneously by
two different groups one at deep mind
it's the bottom one here and then
kingdom and Welling at the University of
Amsterdam so again the idea behind the
the the well latent variable models in
general is kind of represented in this
picture right so here's the space of our
latent variables and we consist this
kind of Representative being fairly
simple we have our two coordinate Z 1
and Z 2 and and they're independent in
this case and they're sort of fairly
regular and they sort of form a chart
for what is our complicated distribution
here in in in X space right so this is
you can think of this is third of the
data manifold so you can think of this
as image space for example right so
image space embedded in pixel space
natural images embedded pixel space form
this kind of manifold and what we want
is
coordinates that allow you to as you
move sort of smoothly in this space move
along this what can be a very
complicated manifold and so that's the
kind of hope that what we're looking for
when we do latent variable modelling so
here's just an example of what I mean by
exactly that this is an early example
using these variational autoencoders so
here's a the freight face data said just
a whole bunch of images of Brendan
Fraser faith that's in the data set what
we're showing here is the model the the
model output of this variational auto
encoder for different values of these
latent variables z1 and z2 now we've
kind of post hawked added these labels
pose and expression on them because you
see if as we move this z2 here you can
see the expression kind of smoothly
changes from what looks like a frown to
eventually smile and through what looks
over here like a thought sting well
sticking his tongue out I guess and in
this direction there's a slight head
turn it's pretty subtle but it's there
so so we do like I said these were sort
of post hoc added the model just
discovered that these were two sources
of variation in the data that were
relatively independent and the model
just pulled those out for something like
m-miss this is the these are samples
drawn on a model train by EM mist it's a
little less natural right because in
this case you could the you could argue
the data is really best model there's
something not with latent factors but
continuously in factors but more like in
clusters so you get this kind of
somewhat interesting somewhat bizarre
relationship where you know you've get
some of this relationship of the tilt
happens here but then that one hurdle
morphs into a 7 which morphs into a 9
and you know because different regions
in this continuous space that represent
different examples here so a little bit
more detail into how we do these kinds
of latent variable models at least in
the context of the variational auto
encoder or VA II model so what we're
trying to learn here is P of X some
distribution over the data we're trying
to maximize the likelihood of the data
that's it but the way we're going to
parameterize our model is with P of X
given
Zed Zetas are latent variables oh sorry
Z I guess for you guys P of X given Z
and then P of Z right some some prior
distribution right so this P of Z here
is is typically something simple right
it's some prior distribution we actually
generally want it to be independent
there's some modeling compromises to be
made there but the reason why you'd want
it independent is because that helps get
you the kind of orthogonal
representation here so these guys this
dimension and this dimension we want
sort of not very much interaction in
order to make them more interpretable
yeah and so and the other thing we want
to do is we want to think about how are
we going to so so going from something
simple like you can think about this is
like in a Gaussian distribution or a
uniform distribution but now we want to
model G here that transforms Zed from
this space into this complicated space
and the way we're going to do that is
with a neural net actually in all of the
examples that I'm going to show you
today the way we're gonna do that is
with a convolutional neural net and the
way to think about that it's a bit of an
interesting thing to think about going
from some fully connected things Zed
into some two-dimensional input with a
topology here in a natural image space X
it's just the way going from what we
talked about it's kind of like the
opposite path of what you would take to
do a confident classification there's a
few different ways you could think about
doing that one of which is called a
transpose convolution this turns out to
not to be such a good idea this is a
case where you essentially fill in a
bunch of zeros it seems like the most
acceptable way to do that right now is
to just once you get some small level
topology here you just you do
interpolation so you just you know super
sample from the image you can do
bilinear interpolation and then do a
comp that preserves that size and then
up sample again comp up sample comp that
tends to give you the best results so
right so when you see this kind of thing
this kind of thing for our purposes
think convolutional neural map alright
so it's important to point out that that
if we had if we had over here
Zed's that gut Wentworth's our Z's that
went with our X
we'd be done right because this is just
a supervised learning problem at this
point and we'd be fine
the trick is these are latent right
they're hidden we don't know of these
sets we don't have we haven't discovered
them yet so how do we learn with this
model
well the way we're gonna do it is we're
gonna use a trick that's actually been
around for quite some time so this isn't
particularly new we're gonna use a
variational lower bound on the data
likelihood right so it turns out that we
can actually express the the data
likelihood here again this is the thing
we're trying to maximize we can express
a lower bound for it given by something
like this so we posit that we have some
Q distribution of Z that estimates is
the posterior of Z for a given X and
we're trying to then I guess maximize
this joint probability over X and Z
minus the log Q Z so this is this is
this variational or bound one of the
ways we can express this is you're
trying to find the Q from Q's point of
view is if you were to find a Q that
actually recovered the exact posterior
distribution over Zed given X this would
actually be a tight lower bound so then
we would for sure be optimizing if we
were now optimized this lower bound we
would be for sure optimizing likelihood
in practice that's what we're gonna do
anyway we're gonna have this lower bound
we're gonna try to optimize we're trying
to raise that up in hopes of raising up
our likelihood but the problem is this
posterior the actual posterior of say of
this G model here there's a neural net
right this is just some forward model
neural net so computing the posterior of
z given x is intractable we have no good
way of doing this it's gonna be some
complicated thing and we have no
sensible way of doing this so we're
going to approximate it with this Q in
this way so we're gonna now we can
actually and what's interesting about
this formulation and this is this is new
to the variational auto queries they've
sort or just reformulated this a little
bit differently and what they've got is
they come up with this this different
expression here which actually can be
thought of in two terms here one is the
reconstruction term here if you look at
what this is this is just you get some
from some queue you get a Zed and you're
just trying to reconstruct X from that
Zed so you start with X you get a Zed
and then
are trying to do a reconstruction of X
from that Zed this is where the name
variational auto-encoder comes from is
because this really looks like an
encoder on the side of Q here and a
decoder here and you're just trying to
minimize that reconstruction error but
in addition to this they add this
regularization term and this is
interesting right so this is what
they're doing here is they're basically
saying well we want to regularize this
posterior and this actually Neela
autoencoders don't have this right so
we're trying to regularize this
posterior to try to be a little bit
closer to the prior here and it's a
common mistake when people learn about
this to sort of think that oh well the
goal is for these things to actually
match that would be terrible right that
that means that you lose all information
about X you definitely don't want these
things to match but it does act as a
regularizer sort of as a counterpoint to
this reconstruction term and so now
we've talked a little bit about this but
what is this q well for the variational
auto encoder the Q is going to be
another neural net and in this case we
can think this is just a straight
Compton at for the case of natural
images so again we've got our lower
bound there objected that we're trying
to minimize and we're gonna parameterize
Q as this neural net the confident that
goes from X to Z and we've got now our
generative model here or decoder that
goes from Z to X I'm gonna add a few
more details to make this thing actually
proc in practice up till now this is not
too new there's been instances of this
kind of formalism of an encoder network
and a decoder network but what they do
next is actually kind of interesting
they notice that that if they
parameterize this a certain way if they
say Q is equal to actually you can use
any continuous distribution here but
they pick a normal distribution here so
Q of X is some normal distribution where
the parameters mu and Sigma from the
defined this normal distribution are
defined by this encoder network then
they can actually encode it like this
it's called a Reaper amortization trick
where they take Z a random variable here
is equal to some function of the input
mu plus Sigma our scaling factor over
some noise and what this allows us to do
now when they formulate it this way is
when in training this model they can
actually back prop
the decoder and into the encoder to
train both models simultaneously it
looks a little bit like this so they can
do forward propagation start with an X
forward propagate to Zed add noise here
that was at epsilon and then for
propagate here to this X hat which is
our reconstruction compute the error
between X and X hat and back propagate
that error all the way through and that
allows them to actually train this model
very effectively in ways that we've
never been able to train before this
this trick came up and when you do that
this is the kind of thing that came out
so this came out in 2014 these were
actually really I promised these were
really impressive results in in 2014
this first time we were seeing sorted
this is not this is from the label faced
in the wild these days we use Celebi and
this is imagenet so not a whole lot
there actually this is a small version
of imagenet but you can do things with
this model actually so for example one
of the things that we've done with this
model is we actually just we talked to I
mentioned briefly this pixel CNN we we
actually include this pixel CNN into the
decoder side so one of the problems if I
just go back one of the problems why we
get these kinds of images is this model
makes a lot of independence assumptions
right and part of it is because we want
those independence assumptions to make
our Zed's more interpretable but they
have consequences to them and one of the
consequences is you end up with kind of
blurry images that's that's part of why
you end up with Bill array images is
because we're making these
approximations in the variational
lower bound and so by adding the pixels
CNN that allows us to encode more
complexity in here and by the way this
is now a hierarchical version of the VA
II using pixel CNN that allows those
allows us to encode sort of complicated
distributions in Zed 1 here given the
upper levels adds and with this kind of
thing this is the kind of images that we
can just synthesize using this
variational we'll call this the the
pixel VA II model so these are bedroom
scenes so you can sort of see it's
reasonably good clear bedroom scenes and
then imaged at which your that you
you can see that it gets roughly the the
textures right it's not really getting
objects yet actually objects that are
really tough to get when you model
things in an unconditional way what I
mean by that is the model doesn't know
that it's supposed to generate a dog
let's say if it was going to generate
something so it's just generating from P
of X in general and it's actually pretty
challenging when we talk about image net
all right so so that's one way we can
improve the the VA II model another way
we can improve the VA you models work on
the encoder side and that was we're done
by a few people but culminating I think
in the inverse auto regressive flow
model so this is actually a very
effective way to deal with it the same
kind of independence problems we saw
they were addressing on the decoder side
but they're addressing it on the encoder
side so you can kind of see just briefly
what this is doing so this is your prior
distribution ideally you would like sort
of the marginal posterior which is
they're like combining all these things
together to be as close to this as
possible because any sort of
disagreement between those two is really
a modeling errors or it's an
approximation error so standard via
email is going to get gonna learn to do
something like this which is it's kind
of as close as it can get to this while
still maintaining independence in the
distributions using this iif method it's
a bit of a complicated method that
involves many many iterations of
transformations that you can actually
compute that are actually invertible
that and you need this to be able to do
the computation but with that you can
get this kind of thing which is pretty
much exactly what you'd want in this
setting so we've played around with this
model and in fact it you know it we find
it works really well in practice
actually yeah but it's again it's on the
encoder side what we were doing with the
pixel vs on the is working on the
decoder side but now so this is actually
fairly complicated both these models are
actually fairly complicated to use and a
fairly involved so one question is is
there another way to train this model
that isn't quite so complicated and so
at the time a student of yoshua bengio
and i and good fellow kate was toying
around with this idea and he came up
with a generative adversarial myths and
the way generative adversarial Nets work
is it posits the learning of a
generative model gee
in the form of a game so it's a game
between this generative model G here and
a discriminator D so the discriminators
job is to try to tell the difference
between true data and data generated
from the generator right so it's trying
to tell the difference between fake data
that's generated by the generator and
true data from the training distribution
and it's just trained to do so this
guy's trained to try to output one if
it's true data and output 0 if it's fake
data and the generator is being trained
to fool the discriminator by using its
own gradients against it essentially so
we back propagate the the discriminate
the discriminator error all the way
through through X we usually have to use
continuous X for this and into the
discriminator now we're going to change
the parameters of the generator here in
order to try to maximally fool the
discriminator so in a sort of a more I
guess abstract way to represent this
looks like this so we have the data on
this side we have the discriminator here
with its own parameters and this again
for our purposes is almost always a
convolutional neural net and then we
have the generator which is again one of
these kind of flipped convolutional
models because it takes noise as input
it needs noise because it needs
variability and then it converts that
noise into something an image space
that's trained with these parameters are
trained to fool the discriminator
alright so you know we can be a little
bit more formal about this this is
actually the objective function we're
training on so let's just break this
down for a second so from the
discriminators point of view what is
this this is just it's called the cross
entropy loss it's literally just what
you would apply if you're doing a
classification with this discriminator
that's all this is from the generators
point of view the generator comes in
just right here right it's the thing you
draw these samples from and it's trying
to minimize well the discriminator is
trying to maximize this quantity this is
essentially likelihood in and and the
discriminative generators moving in the
opposite direction so we can analyze
this this game to see you know there's a
question right there's actually the way
this happened was at first he just tried
it and it worked it was kind of a
overnight kind of thing and we got some
very promising results and then we set
about trying to think about well how do
we actually explain what it's doing why
does this work and so we did a little
bit of theory which is useful to discuss
and I can tell you there's been a lot
more theory on this topic that's been
done that I will not be telling you
about but it's actually been a very
interesting development in the last few
years but this this is a theory that it
appeared in the original paper so the
way we approach this was let's imagine
we have an optimal discriminator this
turns out you can eat pretty easily show
this is the optimal discriminator up
here now you couldn't this is not a
practical thing right because we don't
know PR which is probability of the real
distribution we don't this is not
available to us this is only defined
over training set so only about training
examples so we actually don't you can't
instantiate this but in theory if we had
this optimal discriminator then the
generator would be trained to minimize
the Jenson Shannon divergence between
the true distribution that gave rise to
the training data and our generated
distribution so this is good right this
is telling us that we're actually doing
something sensible in this kind of
nonparametric ideal setting that we
don't we're not really using but but
it's but it's actually it's interesting
nonetheless so one thing I can say
though that in practice we actually
don't use exactly the objective function
that I was just describing what we use
instead is a modified objective function
and the reason is is because if we were
to minimize G what we had before was
this term minimizing G what happens is
is that as the discriminator gets better
and better that the gradient on G
actually exaggerated so it goes to zero
so that's not very useful if we want to
train this model and this is actually
one of these one of the practical issues
that you see when you actually train
these models is that you're constantly
fighting this game between that you're
sort of on this edge of of the
discriminator doing too well or the or
the generator
you know it's it's essentially you're
basically almost always fighting the
discriminator because it's always going
to be as soon as the discriminator
starts to win this this competition
between the Jenner and the discriminator
you end up with unstable training and in
this case you end up with basically the
the generator stops training and the
discriminator runs away with it well
that's actually in the original case so
what we do instead is we optimize this
which is a slight modification but it's
still monotonic and it it actually
corresponds to the same the same fixed
point but but what we're doing is we're
just actually with respect to G again
coming in through the samples here or
maximizing this quantity rather than
minimizing this one okay so that's just
a practical kind of heuristic thing but
it actually makes a big difference in
practice all right so when we did this
when we published first published this
paper this is the kind of results we
would see and what you're looking at now
is kind of movies formed by moving
smoothly and Zed space so this is you're
kind of looking at transformations on
the image manifold coming from smooth
motions in Zed space so we were pretty
impressed with these results again they
felt good at the time but there's been
you know a few papers that have come out
recently well you know not so recently
actually at this point in 2016 there was
a this was came out in 2014 in 2016
there was a big jump in the quality and
and this was sort of one of those stages
this is the least-squares game this is
just one example of many I could have
pointed out but this is the kind of
results for seeing so so part of one of
the one of the secrets here is that it's
128 by 128 so bigger images actually
give you much better perception of
quality in terms of the images but so
these are not necessarily or generally
not real bedrooms these are these are
actually generated from the model right
so trained on you know roughly I think a
hundred thousand or at least a hundred
thousand bedroom scenes has to generate
from these random zed bits this is what
it gives you so one thing you could
think of and one thing that certainly
kind of occurred to me when I first saw
these kinds of results is that well it's
just over fit on some small set of
examples and it's just learning these
Delta functions right so so that
not that interesting some since it's
kind of memorized some small set of data
and it's enough that it looks good and
it's impressive
but it doesn't seem like that's actually
the case and one of the evidence one of
the parts of evidences was pointed to
and this is in the DC Gann paper was
this so that same trick that I showed
you with the movies in EM nough start of
moving smoothly in Zed space they
applied basically that same idea here so
this is basically one long trajectory
through Zed space and what you can see
is starting up here on ending up all the
way down here what you can see is a
smooth transition right and at every
point it seems like you know a
reasonable bedroom scene so it really
does seem like like that picture that I
showed you where we had the Zed space it
was sort of smooth and then we had this
X space that had this manifold on it it
really does feel like that's what's
happening here right where we're moving
smoothly in Zed space and we're moving
along the image manifold in X space so
for example this I guess I don't know if
this is a picture or TV but it's slowly
morphs into a window I guess and then
kind of becomes clearly a window and
then turns just into this edge sort of
an edge of the room so one of the things
actually if you want to nitpick about
these the the models actually don't seem
to understand 3d geometry very well it
often gets the perspective just a little
wrong it's sort of something might be
interesting for future work so yeah so
one question you might be it so why why
do these things work well and they keep
in mind that you know when we talked
about the VA II model we actually had to
do quite a bit of work to get comparable
results right we had to embed these pick
these pixel CN NS in the decoder or we
had to do some quite a bit of work to
get the encoder to work right in these
models we literally just took a
confident stuck in some noise at the
beginning pushed it through and we got
these fantastic samples it really is
kind of that simple so what's going on
like why is it working as well as its
well as it is and so I have a kind of an
intuition for you a kind of a cartoon
view so imagine that
this is the image manifold so so this is
kind of a cartoon view of an image
manifold but like this is in two pixel
dimensions here and and we're imagining
here that these are just parts of image
manifold and they sort of you know share
some features close by but but what this
is basically representing is the fact
that that most of this space isn't on
the image manifold right image manifold
is some complicated non-linearity and if
you were to randomly sample in pixel
space you would not land on this image
manifold which makes sense right
randomly sample in pixel space you're
not getting a natural image out of it
this is sort of a cartoon of you or my
perspective on the difference between
what you see with maximum likelihood
models of which the VA II is one and
something like again so the maximum
likelihood the way it's trained is it
has to give a certain amount of
likelihood density for each real sample
if it doesn't it's punished very
severely for that so it's willing to
spread out its probability mass over
regions of the of the input space or the
error of the pixel space which actually
doesn't correspond to a natural image
and so when we sample from this model
that's most of our samples come from
right this is these are these blurry
images that we're looking at again
models things differently right because
it's only playing this game between the
encoder and well sorry between the
discriminator and the generator all that
has to do is sort of stick on you know
some subset of the examples or maybe
some subset of the manifolds that are
present not and you have enough
diversity that the discriminator can't
notice that it's modeling a subset so
there's pressure on the model to
maintain a certain amount of diversity
but at the same time it doesn't actually
face any pressure to model all aspects
of the training distribution it can just
ignore certain aspects of the training
examples or certain aspects of the
training distribution without
significant punishment from the from the
training algorithm so anyway that's
that's I think a good idea to have in
your mind about the difference between
how these methods work yeah so so just
I'd like to sort of conclude with a few
steps that have happened since the
the gans one of the things this is
something that we've done we've actually
you know what you might ask well ganz
are great but in a way it's kind of
unsatisfying because we start with this
Zed and then we can generate images so
yes we generate really nice-looking
images but but we had this you know hope
when I started talk about these latent
variable Mountain models that we could
actually maybe infer the Z from an image
right so we can actually extract some
semantics out from of the of the image
using these latent variables that you
discover and in the game we don't have
them the question is can we actually
within this generative adversarial
framework can we incorporate inference
mechanism so that's exactly what we're
doing here with this work and it's
actually a model we call Alli but the
identical work essentially came out at
the same time known as baigan and the
basic idea here is just to incorporate
an encoder into the model so rather than
just giving the data distribute the data
set R here on on the Left earlier the
Gann was defined we had the decoder a
generative model but over here we only
gave it X training examples and here we
only compared against X generated from
the DQ from the the generator but in
this case what we're doing is we take X
and then we actually use an encoder here
to to generate a Z given X and on the
decoder we have again our traditional
Gann style we take a sample from some
simple distribution and we generate X so
again this is the data distribution over
here and code it to Zed and then we take
our decode sample from Zed and we decode
to X and our discriminator now crucially
is not just given X but it's given X and
Zed and it's asked can you tell the
difference in this joint distribution
between the end coder side and the
decoder side that's the game and what we
find is well first of all it actually
generates very good samples which is
interesting it's actually it seems to
generate sort of better samples and we
see with comparable Gans which there
might be some regularization effect I'm
not entirely sure why that would be but
actually gets fairly compelling samples
this is just with a cell of a a large
data set of celebrity images but this is
the more interesting plot so so this is
actually corresponds to a hierarchical
version of this model so this is why we
have mult
so this is said one and said two this is
a two layer model in version of this
model so if we just reconstruct from the
higher level Z which is this you know
containing fairly little information
because is this you it's a single vector
and then it has to synthesize into this
a large image what we're looking at here
a reconstruction so we take this image
we encode it to all the way to Z 2 and
then we decode it and what we end up
with is is this which is you know
reasonably close but not that great
right and so it's the same thing you
know kind of all they they sort of hold
some piece of the information which in
some sense this is kind of it it's
remarkable that does as well as it does
because it's actually not trained to do
reconstruction unlike something like the
via II it's actually explicitly trained
to do reconstruction this is just
trained to match these two distributions
and this is kind of a probe to see how
well it's doing because we take X from
one map it to Zed and we take that set
over and when we resynthesize the X and
we see we're seeing now an X space how
close did it come and you know it does
okay but over here when we give it x1 as
z1 and z2 so in this case we're really
just giving it all of the latent
variable information we actually get
much much closer which is interesting is
this is telling us that this pure joint
modelling in this case it would be a
joint modelling between X Z 1 and Z 2
that this is enough to do fairly good
reconstruction without ever actually
explicitly building that in so it's
giving us an interesting probe and - how
close are we coming to learning this
joint distribution and it seems like
we're getting actually surprisingly
close so it's a testament to how
effective I think this generative
adversarial training exam room actually
is so I want to just end with a few
other things that have nothing to do
with our work but I think are very very
interesting and well worth you guys
learning about so first one is cycle
Gann
cycle Gann is this really cool idea
starting with it looks imagine you have
two sets of data sets that somehow
correspond but you don't know the
correspondence you don't have like
there's an alignment that exists between
these two data sets but you might not
know what you know might not have paired
data this actually happens a lot say for
example this is not an image space but a
great example of this happens in machine
translation right
you almost always have lots of
unilingual data so just text data in us
in a given language but it's very
expensive to get a line data but but to
get a paired as a source and target
distribution the question is what can
you do if you just have you and lingual
data how successful can you be at
learning a mapping between the two and
they essentially use ganz to do this so
this is the setup they have some domain
X here and our domain Y here and what
they do is they start with an X they
transform it through some convolutional
neural net usually a resonant based
model into some Y and on this Y they're
going to evaluate it as a just as a as a
gang-style discriminator here so can X
through G make a convincing Y that's
being met what's being measured here so
you can think of X is taking the place
which is you know some other image let's
say this is some image to another image
this image X is taking the place of our
of our Z of our random bits it's getting
its randomness from X and then we do the
same thing we can kind of transform it
through F so we've got X here transform
it through G to D and we evaluate on on
the discriminator here on AG and style
training and then we re encode this in X
now once we get here that's over here so
we've taken X transformed it into Y
transform it back they actually do
what's called the cycle consistency loss
which is this is actually a
reconstruction this is an l1
reconstruction error and they back prop
through F and G and then they it's a
symmetric relationship so they do the
exact same thing on the other side they
start with y they see if they can
transform it into X they compare the
they compare that that that generated X
with true X's via a discriminator and
then again transform that to Y and do
the cycle consistency loss so without
any pair data this is the kind of thing
that they can get so a particular note
is horses and zebras right so and this
is a case where you know it's it's
impossible to get this kind of pair data
say you wanted a transformation that
transformed horses to zebras and vice
versa you will never find pictures of
horses and zebras in the exact same pose
right that's just not a kind of data set
your
be able to collect and yet they do a
fairly convincing job of doing this so
you can see that they even turn like
there's a little bit this one actually
doesn't do it very well but oftentimes
what you see is they turn like green
grass a little bit more savanna like
that kind of dulls it out because zebras
are found generally in Savannah like
conditions they can do winter to summer
kind of transitions I've seen examples
day-to-night these are pretty
interesting very us other things no I
think this there's a lot of interesting
things you can do with this data set and
and going back to if you think about
that simulation example with real
robotics that I gave the motivating
example at the beginning this is a prime
application area for this kind of
technology but I will say that one of
the things that they've done here is
they assume a deterministic
transformation between these two domains
so I think there's a lot of interest
looking at how do you actually break
that kind of restriction and imagine
something more like an many-to-many
mapping between these two domains so the
last thing I want to show you is kind of
the most recent stuff which is just kind
of mind-blowing in terms of just the
quality of generation that they they
show so these are images from Nvidia
actually so I don't know if I'm I'm I'm
sort of undercutting you I don't know if
he was going to show these or not but
yeah so these trained on on the original
celibate data set the same one we had
before but now much much larger images
right so a thousand 24 by a thousand 24
and they're able to get these kinds of
generated models so I would argue that
many of these may be all of the ones
shown here essentially pass a kind of a
Turing test right an image during test
you cannot tell that these are not real
people right now I should say not all
images actually look this good some of
them are actually really spooky but you
can go online and look at the video and
pick some out there yeah how they do
this is with a really interesting
technique and this is actually so new we
have students that are starting to look
at this but we haven't really probed
this very far so I actually don't know
how effective this is in general but
it's actually seems very interesting so
they just start with a tiny 4 by 4 image
and once you train up that parameters
parameters for both the discriminator
here and the generator so again these
are convolutions but we're starting with
with a relatively small input we
increase the size of the input we add a
layer and and and the some of these
parameters here are actually formed by
the parameters that gave you this image
so you sort of just stick this up here
and now you add some parameters and
you'd now train the model to learn
something bigger and you keep going and
you keep going and then you get
something like this as far as I'm
concerned this is sort of this amounts
to kind of a curriculum of training does
two things for you one is it helps build
a bit of global structure to the image
because you're starting with such low
dimensional inputs it helps reinforce
the kind of global structure but it also
does something else which is pretty
important it allows the model to sort of
not have to spend a lot of time training
a very very large model like this right
you wait I would imagine they spend
relatively little time training here
although this is Nvidia so they might
spend a lot of time training this but
but it allows you to spend a lot of the
time sort of in much much smaller models
so much more computationally efficient
to train this model alright so that's it
for me thanks a lot oh wait oh yeah
sorry one more thing I forgot this is
just what they get unconditional image
generation now with m-miss this is again
so you give it horse and then it's able
to generate this kind of thing so far
it's able to generate this right so
bicycles it's able to generate these
which is pretty amazing quality if you
min here you can actually it's kind of
fun because that it kind of gets the
idea of these these spokes but not
exactly like some of them just sort of
end Midway but yeah but still pretty
pretty remarkable
alright so thanks if they have questions
[Applause]